ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนโอเคงั่นอ้ากลับมากลับ
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกับเพียร์ตี้เรียนภาษาไทย
กับเรียม 2  Real หมอแค่วันนี้ในช่อง
คอมเพรนสเบอร์ไทยโอเคอ้าวันนี้เรามาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกันวันนี้วันวันอะไรครับวันนี้วัน
เสาร์
วันนี้วันเสาร์ว้าววันเสาร์แล้วนะครับวัน
นี้เฮ้อวันเสาร์นี่วันนี้วันเสาร์ที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับวันเสาร์ที่ 13 ขอวันนี้วันเสาร์
5 วันที่ 13 เข้ 13 แล้วครับมาแล้วเดือน
อะไรครับเดือนนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนนี้ครับดีหรือสาดจิกายนต์ 5
แล้วปีพศอะไรครับปีพตต
2564 ค่ะอ๋อปีพศ
2564 แล้วปีคศอะไรครับปีคศ
2005  21
ปีคศ 2010  21 โตโอเคอ้าแล้ววันนี้วันนี้
วันนี้ตอนนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันตอนกี่
โมงครับ
5 กี่โมงครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้
9:20 ฮ้าน
09:25 น
21:00 น 21:00 นเป็นเป็นเวลากลางคืนเห็น
ด้วยครับชายค่ะเป็นฟางฟางคืนกลางคืนมีพระ
จันทร์แบบนี้ฮ่าๆใช่ไหมครับอาจารย์ก็
กำลังหลับ
อาจารย์กำลังหลับอ่ะ
09:25 นโอเคอ่ะมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันนะครับ
ก็พรุ่งนี้วันนี้น้องเรียม B อะไรมามี
อะไรมาเรียนกันครับวันนี้วันนี้
อยากตี้กับเตรียมจะพานักเรียนทุกคนไปปลูก
ต้นไม้
ไปปลูกต้นไม้โอเคไปปลูกต้นไม้กันอะเดี๋ยว
พี่เอารูปให้ดูนะครับอ่าพร้อมไหมครับนัก
เรียนซ้อมไหมครับ
เราแล้วไปกันเลยนี่รูปแรกลูกๆนี้นะครับ
อ่าหนูเลียมเห็นอะไรก็เห็นอะไรไหนรูปนี้
บ้างครับเตรียมเห็นเด็กผู้หญิง
มีเด็กผู้หญิงใช่ไหมค่ะนี่เด็กผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้หญิงโอเคมีเด็กผู้หญิงอยู่ 1 คนใน
รูปนี้
ครับใช่ผู้หญิงคนนี้ครับเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้
ทำอะไรครับเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้
เรียงคิดว่าเด็กอ่ะกำลังปลูกต้นไม้ขอปลูก
ต้นไม้อ่ะกำลังลูกต้นไม้
เรียวตีกอล์ฟไหลูกต้นไม้เหมือนกันที่บ้าน
ที่บ้านพี่อาร์ตี้เกาะปู่ต้นไม้อ่ะอ่า
ๆครับชอบ
ๆชอบปลูกต้นไม้ดีแล้วน้องเรียมน้องเรียม
ชอบปลูกต้นไม้ด้วยไหมครับ
เรียงชอบต้นไม้ชอบต้นไม้เจรียมไม่ได้ปลูก
อ้าวไม่ได้ปลูกแต่ชอบใช่ไหมชอบแต่ไม่ได้
ผูกอาเฮียตี้ชอบแล้วพี่ก็รู้ด้วยปลูกต้น
ไม้ด้วย
หึเหมือนเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็ลูกต้นไม้
ครับ
เตรียมเห็นเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้รักผงอ๋ออ๋อ
ร้านผมอ้าโอเคนี้ครับรักผมตรงนี้นะเด็ก
ผู้หญิงผมยาวผมยาวแล้วก็รัดผมเอาไว้ไปทำ
งานก็หน้าเหมือนน้องเรียมนักเรียนก็รักผม
ให้นักเรียนอ่ะ
หน้าร้อนอ๋อก็เลยครับผมรักผมเอาไว้ว้าว
[เพลง]
ต้นไม้เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้ปลูกต้นไม้ต้นไม้
มีสีอะไรครับต้นไม้มีสีเขียวค่ะง่อต้นไม้
สีเขียว
ว้าวชายนี่ต้นไม้สีเขียว
เวลาที่ปลูกต้นไม้
ปลูกในบ้านหรือปลูกนอกบ้านครับจะปลูก
นอก
บ้าน
อ้าวอ๋อปลูกต้นไม้นอกบ้านใช่ไหมครับใครคะ
อ๋อโอเคอ่านี่เด็กผู้หญิงก็นี้ก็ปลูกต้น
ไม้นอกบ้านเหมือนกันน่าปลูกต้นไม้นอกบ้าน
เองเอ๊ะทำไมทำไมต้องปลุกนอกบ้านครับเพราะ
ว่าต้นไม้
อ่ะต้นไม้นะคะแบบนี้อ่ะต้นไม้ครับ
ต้องการแสงแดดอ๋ออ๋อ
แสงแดดแสงแดดคือคืออะไรครับก็คือนี่คือ
พระอาทิตย์อ๋ออ๋อมีพระอาทิตย์ครับก็จะมี
แสงแดดอ๋ออ๋อพระอาทิตย์มีแสงแดดห่ามีแสง
แดดลงมาจากราทิพย์ใช่ไหมต้นไม้ต้นไม้ชอบ
แสงแดดใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะอ๋อก็เลยต้องปลุก
น้อบ้านอ๋อโอเคเพราะว่าในบ้านในบ้านไม่มี
มาให้มีแสงแดด
ถ้าใช่ขอข้างในบ้านข้างในบ้าน
แสงแดดต้นไม้ชอบแสงแดดต้องปลูกนอกบ้าน
เห็ดนี่ค่ะเรียนเตรียมเห็นข้างๆเด็กผู้
หญิงมีอะไรคะอ่ะมีอะไรครับอันไหนครับอัน
นี้ไหมใช่ค่ะอ๋ออันนี้อันนี้เป็นสี่
เหลี่ยมครับ
4 หามา
เสียงไทยทำอะไรคะเสี่ยงใช้ขุดดินขุดดิน
อ่าใช้เสียมขุดดินตรงนี้นะพี่อาร์ตี้
เปลี่ยนสีปากกาเป็นสี
น้ำเงินและกันนี่ขุดดิน
ขุดดินเอาดีมิๆครับเอาดรีมออกไปเอาดินออก
ไปแล้วเอาต้นไม้ต้นไม้ใส่ตัวแทนชายใช้
เสียงมีครับใช้เสียมอานิคุณดินมีเด็กผู้
หญิงก็ขุดดินออกมาจะเอาต้นไม้ใส่ลงไปแล้ว
ก็เอาดินกบอ๊บๆกลบทรายนี่ครับใช้มือใช้
มือกบบดินทร์กกต้นไม้หน่า
จำเห็น
ดินสีน้ำตาลครับ
ดินสีน้ำตาลหาดินสีน้ำตาลเป็นไงครับ
สีน้ำตาลเหมือนผมเด็กผู้หญิงอ๋ออ๋อ
ผมผมสีน้ำตาลหน้าตาดินตาลดินดินก็สีน้ำ
ตาลตาล
เหมือนกันหรอกโอเคแล้วเด็กผู้หญิงก็ใส่
เสื้อผ้า
อ่ะหรอนี่ไปเสื้อสีน้ำตาลด้วยเหมือนกันขอ
ka ก็เพียงตีเห็นเด็กผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อสี
น้ำตาลแล้วก็ใส่ใส่รองเท้า
รองเท้าก็สีน้ำตาลเหมือนกันเหมือนกันโอเค
ว้าวหาใครอ่ะตอนนี้ตอนนี้เด็กผู้หญิงปลูก
ต้นไม้เสร็จแล้วลูกต้นไม้เสร็จแล้วคุณดิน
เสร็จแล้วแล้วทำอะไรต่อครับนี่ลูกต้นไม้
เสร็จแล้วก็ต้องรดน้ำอ๋อนี่ครับเด็กผู้
หญิงกำลังรดน้ำเอ๊ะเขารดน้ำอ่ะ
ใช้อะไรรดน้ำครับใช้บัวรดน้ำอ้วกอ่อนนี้
อันนี้คือบัวน้องบัวนะครับๆเดี๋ยวพี่
อาร์ตี้เปลี่ยนประกาเป็นขีดแดงจะได้ชัดๆ
นี่คือบัวบัวนะครับแล้วก็ใช้รดน้ำ
หน้ารดน้ำแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่า
หา
อ๋ออ๋อรดน้ำให้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ชอบแสงแดด
ชอบแสงแดดใช่ไหมชั้น 5 แล้วก็ชอบน้ำด้วย
ใช่ค่ะชอบแสงแดดชอบน้ำแล้วก็ต้นไม้อยู่ใน
ดินนะมิ 3 อย่าง 3 อย่างที่ต้นไม้ชอบที่
สุดต้นไม้ต้องใช้ 3 อย่างนี้ต้องใช้
แสงดาว 5 แสงแดด ka อ่า
แสงแดดแล้วใช้อะไรอีกครับใช้แนะนำน้ำหน้า
อย่างที่สองเป็นน้ำโอเคแล้วอย่างที่ 3
ดินดินเดี๋ยวเคแค่มีใช้ดินโอเคก็ปลูกต้น
ไม้ได้แล้วไม่มีแล้วพี่อ่ะพี่ล่ะคะเที่ยง
ชอบชอบแสงแดดไหมคะเปลี่ยนชอบนิดหน่อย
ดีไม่ชอบแดดเพราะแดดร้อนแดดร้อน
อ๋อพี่ชอบแดดนิดหน่อยตายแดดนิดหน่อยแดด
ตอนเช้าตอนเช้าแบบไม่ร้อนนะเออแล้วตอน
กลางวันตอนกลางวันแดดร้อนไหมครับเกียร์ติ
ไม่ชอบใช่แล้วน้องเรียมเลยครับนักเรียน
ชอบแดดไหมอ่ะก็เตรียมชอบ
ชอบแดด
500 ครับอ่าชอบแดดอ่ะเมื่อวานว่าถ้าแดด
เยอะๆและร้อนๆแดดร้อนทำยังไงครับ
ไม่ชอบ
ศอ.บตร้อนไม่ชอบร้อนไม่ชอบเออขอ
เหอะแต่ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ท่อบแดดชัยค่ะ
เด็กผู้หญิงรดน้ำต้นไม้แล้วครับเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นต่อไปค่ะอ้าตอนนี้พี่อาร์ตี้สังเกต
เห็นว่าต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นนี้เนี่ย
สูงขึ้นอ๋อ
คุณชายต้นไม้โตโฮขึ้นอ่ะ r0 พื้นอาดูต้น
นี้ต้นนี้ต้นไม้ต้น
ต้นเตี้ยอ่าอาอาใช้ครับต้นเล็กนะครับยัง
ไม่โตต้อง
ต้องให้มีแดดและรดน้ำหน้าแล้วต้นไม้ก็จะ
โตขึ้นนี้นะมีขึ้นหน่อยโหและโตขึ้นมาแล้ว
ๆ
ว้าวแล้วพอต้นไม้โตขึ้นนะต้นไม้ได้แสงแดด
ต้นไม้ได้น้ำ 5 ต้นไม้ได้ดินต้นไม้พอขึ้น
ก็จะมีนี่นี่ต้นไม้เป็นยังไงครับตอนนี้
ต้นไม้
ดอกไม้
ครับมีอีดอกไม้แล้วใช่ไหมต้นไม้มีดอกไม้
หวาน
จะเอาเรียงทิศไม้ดอกไม้สีเหลือง
ดอกไม้สีเหลืองเยอะเลยใช่ครับนี้ดอกไม้สี
เหลืองอ่าเด็กผู้หญิงชอบ
ชอบต้นไม้โตแล้วก็มีดอกไม้เยอะเนอะโอเค
โอเคโอเค
น้าเอ๊ะตีสังเกตสังเกตเห็นตรงนี้
ครับ
พี่เค้าคุณมีตัวอะไรตัวอะไรอยู่บนต้น
ไม้ครับนักเรียน
นักเรียนเห็นไหมคะเห็นไหมเห็นไหมตรงนี้
ตรงนี้อา
[เพลง]
เรียมเห็นหนอนหนอนใช่ไหมครับอ๋อ
ไอ้ตัวนี้เป็นหนอนอ้ามีหนอนอยู่บนต้นไม้
ด้วยโว่ว้าวน้องเรียมกลัวหนอนไหมครับกลัว
มั้ยอิอิหนอนตัวไหมอยู่บ่ก็พี่อาร์ตี้ไม่
กลัวมั้ยอยู่หัวนอน
เด็กผู้หญิงเด็กผู้หญิงกลัวไหมครับเนี่ย
เด็กผู้หญิงกลัวไหมเด็กผู้หญิงก็ไม่หัว
หมอ
ว่าเรียงคิดว่าเด็กผู้หญิงกำลังคุยคุยกับ
หนอนมีกับหนอนใช่ไหมฮ่าๆๆนอนทำอะไรอยู่
อ่ะหนอนทำอะไรหนอนไปไหนอ่ะคุยกับหนอนจัง
นะขอขอ
เด็กผู้หญิงมาให้กลัวหนอนหน้าโอเคแต่น้อง
เรียนพี่น้องเรียมรูๆ
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะครับนักเรียนนักเรียนกลัว
หนอนไหมครับ
พิมพ์ในคอมเม้นที่ในคอมเม้นท์บอกพี่
อาร์ตี้บอกน้องเรียนหน่อยว่านักเรียนกลัว
มั้ยกลัวหนอนไหมกลัวหรือ
ไม่กลัวไม่กลัว
ขอ ka  5 ตอนนี้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้มีดอกแล้วโต
ขึ้นและมีดอกนะครับอ่ะแล้วก็าลังจากนี้
เมื่อต้นไม้มีดอกแล้วนะต่อไปต่อไปจะเป็น
ยังไงครับ
ต้นไม้ก็จะมีผลขออ๋อมีผลมีนี่มีผลแบบนี้
เลยนะครับหามีผลอันนี้เป็นผลของต้นไม้แต่
ถ้าเป็นผลอะไรครับเนี่ย
เตรียมคิดว่าเรียนคิดว่าเป็นผลอะไรครับ
มะเขือเทศอ๋ออ๋อเป็นต้นมะเขือเทศ
ใช่ค่ะมะเขือเทศสีเขียวหรอครับเองเมื่อ
เขือเทศสีอะไรครับ
มะเขือเทศสีแดง
อ้าใช่เพียงตี้คิดว่ามะเขือเทศสีแดง
หาพี่คิดว่ามะเขือเทศสีแดงแต่
ทำไมมะเขือเทศของเด็กผู้หญิงนี้สีเขียว
ครับ
เพราะว่าให้สีสีเขียว
ยังไม่สุกอ๋ออ๋อ
มะเขือเทศยังไม่สุกอ่ะเป็นมะเขือเทศสี
เขียวสีเขียวอ้อเป็นมะเขือเทศสีเขียวยัง
ไม่สุกอ๋อแต่ถ้าเพศสุขหลับเป็นสีอะไรคะ
อ๋ออ๋อถ้ามะเขือเทศสุกแล้วก็เป็นสีแดง
[เพลง]
ง่าถ้าสีแดงสุกแล้วถ้าสีเขียวยังไม่สุก
หน้าสีแดงกินได้ใช่ไหมสีแดงกินได้แล้วสี
เขียวกินได้ไหมครับสีเขียว
กินซะไปกินโรงเรียนเคยกินมะเขือเทศสี
เขียวไหมครับ
เคยค่ะไปช่องต่ำ
ตามโอเคเปียติไม่เคยอ่ะพี่เคยกินสีแดงไม่
เคยกินสีเขียวแต่กินได้ใช่ไหมกินได้
พี่ขอ
โอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้ครับแต่ว่าทีม
เห็นเด็กผู้หญิง
เด็กสาวผู้หญิงห้า
ถืออะไรในมือค่ะอ๋ออ่อเด็กผู้หญิงถือถัง
ทางหนังๆครับเป็นทาง
มีเป็นถ่าง
อาถรรพ์
หาแล้วในถังมีมีอะไรครับมีน้ำมี
5 ตอนนี้เด็กผู้หญิงไม่ใช้บัวและไม่ใช้
บัว 5 นี้ครับอันนี้บัวเด็กผู้หญิงไม่ใช้
บัวแล้วเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงใช้ถังใช้ถังรถน้ำ
น้าทั้งรดน้ำได้เยอะลดน้ำได้เยอะเพราะว่า
เพราะว่าต้นมะเขือเทศโตแล้วโอแล้วต้องใช้
มีน้ำเยอะห่าเด็กผู้หญิงก็เลยใช้ถังรถน้ำ
หน้าได้น้ำเยอะน้อ
[เพลง]
ดีๆอ่ะเปรี้ยวแล้วก็หวานสองอย่างเออได้
ครับ
ว้าว
แล้วก็อัพเขาจะเอามะเขือเทศเอามะเขือเทศ
ไปทำซอสใช่ไหมคะเครียดอีกใช่ใช่ครับเอา
มะเขือเทศไปทำซอสอ่าซอส
เป็นซอสมะเขือเทศ
ขอซอสมะเขือเทศได้ครับเป็นซอสมะเขือเทศ
ได้ครับ
เออชายตอนมะเขือเทศตีกินสอนมะเขือ
เทศกับอะไรคะหน้าเพจติ๊กกินซอสมะเขือเทศ
กับไข่ดาว
ไข่ดาวไส้ๆนักเรียนรู้จักไข่ดาวไหมไข่ดาว
นี้ขี้ไข่ดาวขอไข่ดาวจะเป็นอ่าเดี๋ยวนี้
ใช้ปากกาสีดำ
วาดไข่ดาวกลมๆแบบนี้แล้วก็มีไข่ดาวสีให้
ดาวสีอะไรครับน้องเรียมไข่ดาวสีเหลืองไข่
ดาวสีเหลือง
น่าอยู่ตรงกลางอันนี้เป็นไข่
ดาวแล้วก็กลัวไข่ดาวสีอะไรสีขาวเหรอครับ
ใช่ไหมลอง 7 เอ้าครับนักเรียนเห็นใช่ไหม
ครับอ่ะไข่ดาวแล้วก็นี่ก็กินไข่ดาว
กับซอสมะเขือเทศอ่ะก็เทซอสมะเขือเทศลงไป
กินกับไข่ดาว
คว้าว่าแล้วน้องเรียมน้องเรียมอ่ากินซอส
มะเขือเทศกับอะไรครับ
เตรียมกินซอสมะเขือเทศกับพิษคุณหมออ๋อกิน
ซอสมะเขือเทศกับพิซซ่าว้าวน่ากินจังเลย
อยากกินพิซซ่าแล้ว
Pizza  Hut พิซซ่าไม่ก็ซอสมะเขือเทศว้าว
อร่อยอร่อยใช่ไหมครับเออโอเคอ้าวันนี้เรา
เรียนเรื่องการปลูกต้นไม้ใช่ไหมคะให้มัน
ไม้เขาเคยอยู่ที่ไข่ดาวโอเคอ่าไม่เป็นไร
ปลูกต้นไม้ใช้อะไรบ้างนะครับน้องเรียมที่
ต้นไม้ชอบต้องมีอะไรต้องที่ 1 แสงแดงอ่า
โอเคอ้ามีแสงแดดแล้วก็มีอะไรอีกครับมี
น้ำน้ำชายมีน้ำมาแล้วอย่างที่โอ้หนาม
อย่างที่ 3 ต้องมีอะไรครับอย่างที่ 3
ต้องมี
ดินยินชาย 5 มีแสงแดดมีน้ำแล้วก็มีดินน่ะ
ใช้ปลูกต้นไม้นะครับเออโอเคถ้าอย่างงั้น
เดี๋ยววันนี้นะครับ
ใช่เดี๋ยววันนี้เวลาหมด
นาหมดแล้วใช่มั้ยโอเคเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอ
กันใหม่ข่าวน่ากลัวตี้กับน้องเรียมจะมา
เล่าเรื่องอะไรให้ฟังนะกลับมาเจอกันคราว
หน้านะครับวันนี้พี่อาร์ตี้กับน้องเรียม
ลาไปก่อนครับถ้าต้องลาไปก่อนรอดูครั้ง
หน้าค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพวกพี่สวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมสวัสดีครับนักเรียนดีค่ะนักเรียน
บ๊ายบายน
ม.ค